[Musique]
sauf très république et heures un groupe
qui agrège les compétences très
complémentaire de cinq grands acteurs
[Musique]
c'est une opportunité l'opportunité de
travailler les logiciels les logiciels
qui vont être le coeur de la valeur
future de la mobilité
[Musique]
chacun des cinq acteurs apporte sa
pierre à l'édifice dans un système ya
bien sûr les acteurs membres fondateurs
qui ont été annoncés mais également des
start up des centres de recherche des
universités qui ensemble vont travailler
dans ce nouveau monde digital de la
mobilité
les voitures seront effectivement des
capteurs des absorbeurs des générateurs
de données renault va apporter à ce
programme de la soirée publique et bien
le véhicule finalement c'est qui est un
peu un petit peu notre force mais
également le travail sur les nouvelles
mobilités et atos dans le domaine les
compétences autour du calcul en calcul
intensif de plus en plus miniaturisés
embarqué autour de la sécurisation des
objets donc des voitures et de
l'environnement qui le tour l'idée est
que ces nouvelles mobilités soit
décarbonée aujourd'hui ces émissions
dues aux transports représentent 23 %
des gaz à effet de serre et le travail
de la software république va nous
pousser à descendre ce ce chiffre le
plus bas possible que la voiture devient
objet digital et s'assurer que dans
cette
dans cet environnement informationnel la
voiture évolue de manière sécurisée
les équipes travaillent déjà ensemble
mais maintenant on va les réunir dans un
même lieu
qui est ce qui s'appelle le bâtiment
odyssée sur le technocentre sur le
plateau de saclay donc avec la proximité
des centres de recherche des grandes
universités des équipes qui
travailleront en fonction des besoins et
de manière totalement flexible et
ouverte
et effectivement on ira puiser dans les
équipes des différentes des niches
industrielles participants et on sera
tous ensemble l'idée est de le faire
ensemble de travailler ensemble sur des
projets clairement identifiés ça sera
vraiment au fur et à mesure que les
projets avanceront que l'on mettra plus
ou moins les équipes de manière très
agile et flexible aux services de
sauvetage public